beginnt hier europa am sogenannten tor
europas mich berührt sie immer wieder
die installation von mimmo paladino ein
denkmal für all die flüchtlinge die hier
retten den europäischen boden erreichen
wollen
der italienische objektkünstler macht
vor sechs jahren zum thema was auch in
der entfernten schweiz viele umtreibt
was passiert rund um lampedusa zwischen
afrika und europa
diese frage stellt auch samir das
festival der mediterranen kultur an
einem ort der bei mir viele erinnerungen
wachruft an flucht und tragödie aber
auch an hoffnung und rettung
wie diese flüchtlingsboote die auf
lampedusa ihre menschen fracht abgeladen
haben
auf diesem schiffsfriedhof treffen wir
ascanio cellisten autor und regisseur
aus rom
er inszeniert theater hier vor ort und
erzählt mir dass er provozieren
das scheitern der europäischen
migrationspolitik zum thema seiner
festivalbeiträge machen möchte die
arbeit hier soll gegensätze deutlich
machen wollen wir beim thema migration
die ursachen vergessen mit nummern und
zahlen rein technische lösungen finden
oder wollen wir die heutigen probleme
lösen indem wir aus den fehlern der
vergangenheit lernen
der skrupellose kommandantin celestini
stück entscheidet sich für die nummern
und zahl
migration ist für ihn nur ein geschäft
für das er buch führt über leben und tod
anderswo werden interviews auf
leintücher und häuserwände projiziert
einheimische erzählen von ihrer
hilfsbereitschaft gegenüber migranten
aber auch von der überforderung
angesichts dieses ansturms
die einen wollen dass die ganze welt
über lampedusa redet als ort wo
flüchtlinge aufnahme finden die anderen
sagen schluss mit dem thema
lampedusa ist doch nicht nur flucht und
tod letztendlich bleiben auf der insel
die flüchtlinge aber das bestimmende
thema nicht allen in lampedusa aber
passende ideen dieses festivals die
gegner treffen sich auf dem hauptplatz
sie fordern wirtschaftshilfe und kein
kulturspektakel allein dieses jahr
fehlen 40 prozent touristen
sie wollen über unsere probleme hier
reden bitte schön aber nicht in unserem
namen ihres festival organisiert kommen
ja nicht einmal aus lampedusa
mir wird erklärt dass viele gerede um
die flüchtlinge würde dem image der
insel schaden
doch ich frage mich warum herrscht bei
nur 6000 einwohnern hier soviel
zwietracht
so wird die protestaktion schnell zur
selbstinszenierung die gegner dieses
festivals teil der kunstaktionen im
öffentlichen raum lampedusa bleibt ein
großer widerspruch
spätestens auf dieser abfallhalde spüre
ich das einfach hingeworfen ein
schlauchboot mit den flüchtlingen aus
afrika die überfahrt gelang drin liegen
noch die wasserflaschen fruchtsäfte und
sogar eine packung schmelzkäse
eigentlich unglaublich da diskutieren
die lampedusa über ihre eigene rolle in
diesem europäischen flüchtlings und
gleichzeitig unterhalten sie hier eine
wilde mülldeponie wo sie einfach alles
ablagern was ihnen unnütz erscheint was
für viele flüchtlinge aber vielleicht
ihr letztes hab und gut bedeutet neuen
wert gibt diesen gegenständen jakobus
verletzung in lampedusa aufgewachsen
sammelt der künstler schiffsplanken und
andere überreste aus den alten
flüchtlingsbooten daraus schafft er
bilder und collagen und will so die
geschichte der vielen namenlosen
migranten bewahren nennt man sie
migranten oder schlimmer noch illegal
wird man diesen menschen nicht gerecht
das sind ganz normale menschen die haben
sich diese situation nicht ausgesucht
essen hören musik putzen zähne benutzen
die fotos milchflaschen zigaretten
die sammlung ist politisch längst schon
hätte europa eine alternative finden
müssen für die gefährliche fahrt über
das meer nach lampedusa
nie hat man versucht diesen menschen
eine reguläre einreise zu verschaffen
unsere politik zwingt sie zur
illegalität trotz traum küsten und
traumstränden lampedusas schicksal
bleiben die flüchtlinge daran werde ich
bei diesem besuch immer wieder erinnert